say hello to Jim Nantz everybody hello
friends yeah thank you dan the man with
Dan Nets or my buddies great to be back
with all of you you know we had that
moment we actually had a moment together
Jim a couple of weeks ago at your house
at Pebble Beach so just so people know
and you could go to Dan Patrick calm and
you're able to see the video so Jim John
says why don't you come over and he
doesn't live too far from the driving
range where we were going our showed he
said come on over I want you to have
breakfast I said to the dance let's go
so we get there and then we have great
breakfast Jim caters it we're out on the
veranda we're overlooking you know this
par-3 7th at Pebble Beach by the way
when I come back in my next life I want
to be Jim Nantz so so we he says come on
and back we're gonna I got a we're gonna
hit some golf balls I get some wedges I
he's recreated the par-3 7th at Pebble
Pebble Beach
so it's sort of just I think to scale
right yeah it's about half the size okay
everything so we get in there Jim gets
his phone out got a little app there
next thing you know I got the Masters
music playing birds chirping and Jim's
two one play-by-play as we're hitting
wedge shots into the par-3 7th was that
like one of the greatest days it was so
much fun to one seed it was that's one
of those that the one seat I like it
yeah it was it was wonderful and so it
came down to Jim and I where you know
it's toe to toe here I mean this is
basically Tiger Woods Jack Nicklaus we'd
lay down the challenge earlier on the
show I I made some unflattering remarks
about your golf game I didn't realize
you were that good bring these birds in
with you yes you brought those from you
bring those birds with you and travel
with me yeah that is the melody yeah
it's a constant loop I like that ringing
in my head I love it
but it was a fright down to the wire
riveting competition if it was and I
think Seaton may have been the closest
one of the bunch our shots that we came
down to at the end we're not star worthy
I mean I barely got it on the green I
was choking so hard but I beat you you
did barely
he showed me a lot I mean I was
impressed by your golf it's called moxie
I got moxie thanks Dan yes you did a lot
of it really and then Jim gave us
parting gifts he has wine called the
calling so we went into the wine cellar
and you loaded this up yeah a couple
your guys we couldn't get out of the
wine cellar 56° surprise Seton didn't
stay in there and they didn't make it
home for Monterey if you know what I
mean down there yeah if you had a cot in
their seat and what I said in there have
you ever lost your voice I have actually
on the air I was doing a game at
Stanford a basketball game years ago
with Billy Packer and I knew I was in
trouble when I awoke that morning in
Palo Alto I knew I was gonna have a hard
time be able to hit hit the notes and
everything and I expressed that to to
some folks back in New York struggling
as I was on the phone and I called the
executive producer at the time and told
him I said I've got a real problem I
think we need a backup he said when the
red light goes on you'll be fine like my
voice is suddenly gonna react to this
and the red light came on and I nothing
came out and Billy ended up calling the
whole game we were on a two-shot on the
on-cameras everything I couldn't say
anything it became a comedy act
basically is this I couldn't I did not
he'd read the promos he did it all I
couldn't do anything
wait would you just sat there I just sat
there I tried to squeak a few words out
it was painful it's painful the one I
always worry myself with is next week
because the pollen count is really high
in the custom worried about so you got a
rough life you're worried about the
pollen we put it in context of a voice
but there was a there was a span of
about five years where I'd go to Augusta
coming off the tournament tired having
called 15 or 18 games and like a month
and then I'd go to Augusta and and I
would just lose my voice the Year Tiger
of course had the win for the ages in
1997 on the Friday night before the
weekend I actually had to go to a
hospital in Augusta and get a cortisone
shot and they said it would help the
steroid would help get my voice back and
and I called his Saturday round of 65
from inside Butler cabin I I was I never
saw a golf shot live I couldn't go out
they told me stay out of the air so I
stayed ensconced inside Butler calling
shots off of a monitor while Ken Venturi
was up in the 18th hole
we never stepped on one another we had a
little system back and forth where I
would finish my comments with Ken even
in this his comments calling Jimmy he
always called me and it sounded like we
were right there on the 18th hole on the
18th hole is it turns out Tiger spun his
2nd shot off the off the back of the
green and it rolled up there about three
feet away and he of course made birdie
to go into the night with a nine shot
lead and I called it without ever seeing
a shot I think the headline out of this
is Jim Nantz on steroids I think we have
suspected you've been on steroids that
why the voice sounds like we do have the
Jim Nantz sound alike contest that'll be
next week with Augusta Jim did not win
the Jim Nantz sound alike contest one
hear what's true you finished second
place but that that's admirable for you
any advice for people who want to take
part of me Jim Nantz sound alike contest
this year b-positive the one to speak
from the heart
a lot of passion you know this is not
the don't be angry don't be mean
spirited you have a go to word that
there there right there there it is he
brought the mutant I am I the only one
hearing this cuz it does play in my head
all the time or is that really on the
air right now
he brought his piano unbelievable
welcome friends to this tradition unlike
any other the Masters on CBS
I am looking forward to it I am so
excited about these next 9 or 10 days I
mean my gosh thank you Lord for giving
me the chance that honestly to do this
for the 33rd time they call the final
four to go to Augusta I am so grateful
so getting back to my advice mm-hmm
try to speak with a grateful heart okay
and I'm not kidding here that's how I
feel when I broadcast the Masters
Tournament I do it from the heart
whatever that means
I just let the words flow I don't do it
with a bunch of notes any notes in front
of me I just tell people what I'm
feeling at the moment what I see and
observe we know the players for so many
years we have all the anecdotal
information catalogued in our heads I
don't need that I don't need reminders I
could go on for hours about any one
player and what a week it's gonna be
with all the top players in peak form
heading to Augusta and Tiger coming back
to compete Rory going for the Grand Slam
and Phil off a but win and bub off a two
wins on the last five weeks and Justin
Rose's game is on go and Jason Day one a
couple of months ago Justin Thomas is
the Player of the Year last year and his
game is in peak form Dustin Johnson's
still number one in the world I'm sorry
what was your question I forgot okay if
I gave you Loyola wins the national
title or Tiger wins Augusta
what's a better story I don't I don't
want to diminish the value of either one
of them two sports it's kind of hard to
compare the loyal will win would be I
think it would be take precedent as you
know we called Villanova in 85 the
Cinderella but it coming out of a major
conference
they'd played Georgetown and lost but
they'd play Georgetown a couple of times
during the season and yes it was a
tremendous win for a nine seed or eight
see whatever they were now you go to
Loyola and if they were to win I mean
this would truly I think they've already
captured the hearts of America I think
they're playing for a lot more than just
the campus you know you've seen all the
excitement naturally at Loyola Chicago
but the sister Jean story this this is
it's transcending just
that school I think there are a lot of
people that have really tapped into this
underdog and I think they are fully
capable of winning this championship I
really do
the tiger story if Tiger wins Augusta
and by the way maybe it's not this year
maybe it's next year but when that
happens if that happens it would it
would rank right up there with jack
winning the Masters in 1986 it would be
one of the biggest stories in the
history of the game so I don't know you
you weigh it that's a fair question I
guess I hate to compare the two but I
think they're both very possible what's
more surprising the run the tiger had
when he couldn't lose to the run where
he couldn't win what's more surprising
to you you're now you're going back to
when he was healthy when he dominated
winning oh it's US Open and he did have
obviously health issues broken leg he
wanted Torrey and but it came back and
had like a great season in 2013 but
didn't win the majors I think that the
the astonishing thing was the way he won
and had the the bigger of the two that
was more surprising as to someone could
take the game and claim it and call it
his own for that long that you know he
won seven out of 11 majors at one at one
stretch including four in a row
concluding with the oh one masters which
we called the tiger slam in it it was it
was a stretch of golf that I don't think
the sports ever gonna see again I mean I
think that will be the greatest run in
the history of the game now what's
interesting is that if you look at some
of the technology where we can monitor a
player's ability now Tigers swing speeds
speed translates to distance in golf
higher speed longer the shot his swing
speeds after all these back surgeries
and everything he's back to what he was
when he was in that dominant stretch
which is almost inconceivable for a guy
that's 42 years old and it's gone under
the knife as many times as he has so
it's it's been amazing to watch these
handful of events that he's come back
and he's played so well he's been on the
fringe of contending been close and he's
going to Augusta and you know he's gonna
be a factor there Jim Nantz joining us
here in San Antonio the sporting event
you haven't called is what that you want
to anything you missed out on the only
thing I can think of would be like the
Danette sand some sort of three-on-three
basketball competition maybe three on
three one guy will sub in every once in
a while listen there's nothing out there
that I want to do I'm not qualified to
call a lot of the events that I haven't
called I never called the World Series I
am I don't have the ability to do that I
I couldn't talk the sport to the level
that needs to be done to honor the game
and it's just it's it's not something
that I would be qualified to do we got
great play-by-play guys and and baseball
Joe does it of course in the World
Series it's exceptional I would never be
able to do that they won one sport I I
really wanted to do for a long time one
sporting event is I wanted to call the
Open Championship or as we don't know
what over here is the British Open yes
the world knows that is the Open
Championship and that that word
circulated back to the RNA and the BBC a
few years ago and they gave me that
opportunity and I did that event for a
number of years and was the IMP was the
guy with the accent on it on the
broadcaster's they said and I got to
call three or four in limited roles but
I got to do the Open Championship and it
was a thrill you get nervous doing
anything anything laughs absolutely this
weekend Saturday Final Four you're gonna
get nervous I got nervous last night I
hosted the opening ceremony it's called
the NCAA salute is at this beautiful
Convention Center and all the teams come
in and I always feel some nervous energy
if that's what it is about doing it
doing it right doing it justice and
giving these kids a moment that they
won't forget and it was a it was a
special gathering the coaches were there
and you know gathering of about a
thousand and it's the basketball
community and yeah I felt I thought
little bit jittery before that I will
tomorrow for sure and we have a little
traffic to do we've talked in the past
about handing out the trophies and you
do that so well at the Super Bowl when
it's your year and and I get to do this
at a number of occasions I'll have it
Monday night that chance in the
following week of course the green
jacket in Butler cabin those are ones
you really want to hit on and in
addition to that at the Final Four out I
will set the lineups
that'll be simulcast inside the building
and and and around the nation and that's
that's a big responsibility I'd like to
get through that with it being clean
yeah and that's really important to me
mark wolf our producers been working on
this for months Bob Fishman our director
there's gonna be some sort of 3d laser
thing happening on the floor
introducing the line of you it's gonna
be you never been done before to my
knowledge and I've got to work somehow
in harmony with that and and hopefully
not screw it up the dance had a question
the show was nominated for a Sports Emmy
Jimmy I saw that by the way very well
deserved one thing and I trust you guys
absolutely how about it thank you and I
know Dan got nominated to is a studio
hose which is also quite meritorious so
I'm pulling for you guys wait did you
say miraculous then I got nominated
merit okay I thought it was miraculous
oh yeah Paul your question Dan Jim Nantz
you're one of our favorites and you been
to the sports Emmys probably a thousand
times and gotten a bunch can we have a
table at the sports Andy's can we bring
beer what's the etiquette there I don't
think that I mean III I don't think they
have it said I was on a table it's not a
thing it's quite set up like that it's
like it it's an auditorium leave out the
table part can we bring beer
can you bring beer you'll have to you'll
have to sneak it into the building I
would expect nothing less for me that's
not a no you just said you're gonna to
sneak it in oh it's all you're gonna say
gonna bring the calling and now I would
have helped you there
[Laughter]
any other questions for Jim that was it
huh that's the best you could come up
with Paul but we're not very deep we're
new here we're new here yeah now you're
surprised eating the come on Satan I'm
all about cowboy booty those are serious
these are I got these in San Antonio as
a gift the Valero Texas Open by the way
I love San Antonio it is from the bottom
of my heart this is my 33rd final for
the final four should be in San Antonio
no less than every third year it's been
ten years we should be here like a
couple years from now there's not a
better sight and this is how it's
supposed to be experienced where people
can get together coexists the four teams
and all their fan bases and getting out
this is a city's beautiful and it's
slightly it's kind of poulsen I love it
I've been here for all them there's been
my fourth call of a Final Four here we
should be in San Antonio all the time so
I got these I got these boots during the
Valero Texas Open which is coming here
in a few weeks they do a great job of
running that event and he gave it to me
as a gift on on what was my 50th
birthday yeah which was really nice and
I I love him whenever I do a Cowboys
game anything that brings me back to
Texas
I bring the boots yeah absolutely all
right we came up with some you always
have to do this juxtaposition of your
you know deep into a game and then you
have to do they give you a card a little
promo card coming up little car yeah a
blue card tell with you 60 minutes so we
came up with some these are not actual
shows so I I would like for you if you
could to rate some promos here yeah so
just imagine I'll give you the paper
here
George Schweitzer is is our man at CBS
okay so let's just say you're in the
middle of a game and you're gonna tell
us what's coming up on CBS and that is
the name of the show that's coming up
this is Sunday night yeah Sunday night
tonight on CBS begins with 60 minutes
followed by the
odorless smell okay and then an all-new
episode of NCIS Los Angeles on America's
number one now okay all right now go to
the next page we came back with there's
a few more TV shows there so can I read
all that you can if you want those are
other shows we came up with that maybe
CBS is interested in a unique
commonality tonight on CBS after
football after our NFL game stupidity as
genius on CBS
I like these oxymoron so overdressed and
naked tonight on CBS silent noise
they're all kind of the same yeah they
are you know yeah yeah Ritchie came up
with the okay
wait which one I can't do the humility
of arrogance 60 minutes okay now three
more on the next page now these could be
real CBS shows all right so here we go
here's Jim Nantz well is I think you're
missing I think you misspelled this Paul
that would you wouldn't do that par for
the course Jim a reminder tonight CSI
Duluth on CBS that's not an actual show
not yet after 60 minutes the bigger Bang
Theory the stormy Daniels story next on
CBS after basketball on America's number
one network George Schweitzer we've
reached a low here
Jim Nantz weekend we'll talk to you next
week I'll see you at the Emmys for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show at
you